Let me start with a little story, because I think it'll help explain the technicalities
of what's actually happening behind the scenes.
So imagine a website where you can post images and comments underneath.
So think of, say, Facebook.
But I'm not suggesting Facebook is vulnerable to this, okay?
You need to find a vulnerable website.
But let's just all think about Facebook, because there's probably a website we're all
familiar with.
So I log into Facebook one day, and I noticed that my buddy has posted a picture of him
and his daughter.
And being the very good friend that I am, I decide to post a comment underneath.
And so I write something like, oh, what a lovely picture.
It's too bad she looks just like you do.
So that's the crappy comment I leave.
Now what happens when I hit submit?
That comment gets sent to Facebook servers.
The comment is stored in a database somewhere.
And now every subsequent user that goes and views that picture is going to see my crappy
comment underneath.
And so what's happening is my comment data is actually being stored on the server.
And then every subsequent user that visits the website, that HTML code contains the
comment.
And the user's browser is downloading that comment, and it's displaying it, like it's
supposed to.
So that's the scenario, okay?
Now, here's what's going to happen.
Our baddie here, you can tell they're baddie, right, the fedora.
Our baddie here is going to discover a vulnerable website, and it has to be a vulnerable website,
which I'll explain why in a few minutes.
So our baddie discovers a vulnerable website.
And here's what our baddie does.
Our baddie injects some malicious code into the web page.
And that sounds very technical, doesn't it?
But it could literally be as simple as typing some code in a comment field and hitting submit.
And what's the code that you're going to type into the comment field of the website?
JavaScript.
Now why does it have to be a vulnerable website?
Well, because no website should ever just accept JavaScript code as a comment and store
that code in the database, and especially then redisplay all that code to every user.
But that's why our baddie discovers a vulnerable website.
So our baddie injects the code into the web page into the website, they submit their comment,
the comment gets stored on the server.
Now what happens?
Every subsequent user that visits that website, their browser is going to download the web
page, and embedded in that web page is going to be the JavaScript code.
And their browser is going to do exactly what it's designed to do.
Their browser is going to parse the HTML page, it's going to come across the JavaScript,
and it's going to execute the JavaScript, it's what it's designed to do.
And now when our victim's browser executes that JavaScript code, what typically happens?
Well, some data is sent back to our baddie here.
So this is an example of stored cross-site scripting.
Why do we call it stored?
Well, it's because the JavaScript code is stored on the server.
We also call it persistent, and the reason we call it persistent is because every subsequent
user that goes to this particular page and views, you know, and downloads this malicious
code, it's going to execute on their browser.
So stored, persistent, cross-site scripting.
Now let's talk about another type of cross-site scripting.
This is known as reflected cross-site scripting.
So I'm going to set up another little scenario to help you imagine how this works.
Imagine going to a website like Google.com.
When you go to Google, when you go to Google.com, and you type in a search query in the search
bar and hit search, what happens?
Well, the search results page says, here are your search results for cat or dog or whatever
you've searched for.
So imagine that scenario, OK?
So here's what's going to happen.
Our baddie is going to do, again, discover a vulnerable website.
And our baddie is going to first create a URL.
A URL stands for a universal resource locator.
This is what you type up in your browser bar to go to a particular site or page on a
website.
And what our baddie is going to do here is think of Google.com again.
When you type in Google.com and you search for something, the search results URL page will
say Google.com, question mark, search equals, whatever you searched for.
Our baddie is going to create a URL for like that, except in the search field, instead of
putting in some word or some sentence, what's our baddie going to put in the URL?
JavaScript code.
So our baddie creates this URL containing the JavaScript code.
Sends it to our victim here.
And through some sort of social engineering technique, maybe phishing or something like
that, our baddie here somehow convinces the user to click on the URL.
When the user clicks on the URL, that sends the request to the web server.
The web server is going to then reflect that code back to the user.
It's like the search.
It's like the page is saying, here are your search results for JavaScript code.
So the website is going to reflect the malicious code back to the user.
The malicious code is going to be contained in the page that comes back to the user.
And once our users browse are going to do, exactly what it's designed to do.
It's going to parse through the page, hit the malicious JavaScript code and execute it.
And once the final step here, well, this malicious code is going to run and it's going to send
some data back to the baddie once again.
So overall, it's the same effect, which is the target of attack here is the user.
And in both stored and reflected and, sorry, in both stored and persistent and reflected
cross-site scripting, it's all about sending data back to the baddie.
But in reflected cross-site scripting, there's a few important things to understand here.
Number one, why do we call it reflected cross-site scripting?